مو جزء الاخبار اهلا بكم قالت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه ان القوات الروسيه
كثفت قصفها على المناطق الماهوله بالسكان
في مقاطعه خرسون وزبوروجي يا جنوبيه
البلاد
واضافت الهيئه ان اكثر من 20 بلده في زبرج
يتعرضت للقصف المدفعي خلال ساعات الماضيه
اضافه الى استهداف الكره الواقعه على خط
التماس في خرسان
وقد قال الرئيس الاوكراني
في اوكرانيا لدعم الامكانات القتاليه على
الجبهات المختلفه
اوكرانيا ستفعل كل شيء من اجل مصر
من جانبه قال ناطق باسم وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان القوه الروسيه تتقدم في محورين
دونيت سكواز براجيا واضاف انها قتلت نحو
300 عسكريا اوكراني في 30 جبهات
يعقد وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي
اجتماعا اليوم في بروكسل يبحث قضايا من
بينها الحرب في اوكرانيا في غضون ذلك ذكرت
صحيفه
المجلس الاوروبي حتى قاده الاتحاد على
المضيق قدما في محادثات بشان استخدام ما
يصل الى 300 مليار دولار من اصول البنك
المركزي الروسي المجمده لاعاده اعمار
اوكرانيا
ذكرت وكاله تاسه روسيه ان السفينه الحربيه
الروسيه ادميرال جوشكوف ستشارك في تدريبات
المشتركه مع الصين وجنوبي افريقيا الشهر
المقبل واضفت الوكاله ان السفينه مزوده
بصواريخ من الجيل الجديد تفوق سرعتها سرعه
الصوت بتسع مرات ويبلغ مداها اكثر من 1000
كلم
قال رئيس الوزراء الياباني
ستقود الجهود في قمه مجموعه السبع القادمه
للوصول الى عالم من الاسلحه النوويه وقال
في خطاب امام البرلمان ان تطوير كوريا
الشماليه صواريخ نوويه هو انتهاكم للقانون
الدولي وتهديد لامن وسلامه
ستعمل بجد لضمان ان تكون منطقه المحيطين
الهندي حره ومفتوحه امام الملاحه الدوليه
ينظم اعضاء كنيست من حزب اللكود
الاسرائيليه اليوم جوله على مشارف تجمع
الخان الاحمر شرقي القدس المحتله في خطوه
تهدف للضغط على حكومه نتنياهو لهدم التجمع
وتهجير سكانه ودعت هيئه مقاومه الجدار
والاستيطان بالتعاون مع محافظه القدس الى
تنظيم الفاعليه احتجاجيه بالتزامن مع
زياره اعضاء من حزب اللكود الى التجمع
والتاكيد على التصدي لقرار الهدم
قال الرئيس الفرنسي انه ينتظر ما سيصدر
رسميا عن رئيس المرحله الانتقاليه في
بوركينا فاسو بخصوصي مطالبه بلاده بسحب
قواتها من هناك ولمح الرئيس الفرنسي الى
وجود علاقه لروسيا بهذا الموضوع
[موسيقى]